maybe this hospitalization numbers
aren't actually reflective of people who
are in the hospital rather it's with
covid rather than from covet now this
also ties into our conversation about
the suppression and censorship on
Twitter and Elsewhere for a long time
that was considered a conspiracy theory
and you're crazy well it turns out
that's true and I reported on these two
studies that were done on pediatric
Admissions and at the time at least 40
percent of the Pediatric coveted
emissions were unrelated to covet a kid
maybe they broke their foot or something
and they had to test them for covid and
they just incidentally had covid but it
had nothing to do with why they were in
the hospital but nevertheless that was
added to the tally just very quickly I
had a joke that I tweeted during the
pandemic I said my grandfather died with
his wife by his side but it was the
middle of the pandemic so they decided
he died of her and put her in prison
anyway